[Music]
so good so whoops
so so hello everybody my name is sheila
mcelrath i'm from the department of
computer science at the university of
toronto
we cannot see your screen do you want to
share the screen oh you can't see it oh
okay i thought i'd already shared it
um just a sec
yeah rupak was going to introduce you
after you share yeah i mean i can
maybe i do the introduction yeah uh
okay so um hello everyone
it's my pleasure to introduce sheila
mcelrath
from the university of toronto and she's
going to talk about connections between
formal languages and automated theory
and
efficient reinforcement learning so
please take it from here
thank you for coming
ah you're muted now
thanks uh thanks for puck and people can
feel free to
interrupt me if they have questions i'm
not watching the chat but but i know
rupak said that he would so
so indeed my talk is about the
opportunities and some work that we've
done on exploiting formal languages
and automata for both rewards
specification
and efficient reinforcement learning
and before i i jump into the details i
wanted to acknowledge my graduate
student rodrigo toro
carter who who is the the lead author on
much of the work that i'm going to be
discussing today he's some of the work
though is in collaboration or
all of the work is in collaboration with
at least tauren classen
and rick valenzano who and uh who are
student center of a postdoc with me
and i'll also be mentioning work by
alberto camacho
leon elena's and some of the other
co-authors that you see on here all of
whom are
students or former students of mine so
i wanted to motivate this notion of
using formal languages for reward
specification by really sort of stepping
back and thinking about
um an end a motivating end task which is
really to address this problem of
how we might be able to advise instruct
or actually
task you know request uh request our
agent to do something for us or impart
knowledge to some sort of a
reinforcement learning agent
and you can and you can imagine a robot
in your home that you might hire
or that you might bring into your home
that has some set of skills but you'd
still like to be able to tell it what
you wanted to do you want to have some
sort of communication with that
that agent and how do we go about doing
that so
um i know that i have a varied audience
here so i wanted to just
step back for a minute and talk about
reinforcement learning i think many of
the people
who are here are used to um using linear
temporal logic or some sort of or mdps
or some sort of other formalism
to construct models and and then solve
these sort of program synthesis
or policy generation problems strategy
generation problems using
using games or some sort of other
formalism the paradigm that we're
looking at here today is reinforcement
learning and in particular model free
reinforcement learning
and the idea here is that we have an
agent
and the agent just has a set of actions
that it can perform in the world
and what it wants to do is it wants to
learn a policy a mapping from state
to action or action distribution that
will maximize
its its expected cumulative reward so
the agent performs an action in the
environment
and the environment um tells it what
state it's in
and what reward it gets and it does
another action and
and the environment tells it what state
it's in and what
reward it gets so the agent knows the
actions that it can perform but it
doesn't know the transition system and
it doesn't know the probability
distribution of the transition
system similarly it doesn't know the
reward function
so it's just it's like walking around in
the dark trial and error trying to
figure out what you want to do
through some sort of reward signal that
you're receiving from the environment
so just very quickly one way of doing
model free reinforcement learning is
through an algorithm called q
learning which i'll refer to a little
bit later and i just wanted to give you
um the 20-second view of it so
q stands for quality um a
q function talks about the quality of a
particular state
and a particular action and as we're
learning as we're performing experiences
in the world as the agent is performing
experiences in the world
it's going to update it's going to learn
more about the quality of each state
action pair and it's going to update
those values so it's going to start
and that update is going to be a
function of what it what it
its current belief about the quality of
that
state action pair plus
that alpha is a learning rate how much
it wants to consider
um what it's just experienced in terms
of of
updating its its quality assessment for
that state action pair
and that quality so the alpha is the
learning rate it's something it's a
number between zero and
one uh uh round bracket
um and and that's comprised in turn of
the
current reward that it just got from the
experience that it had
plus some discounted gamma's a discount
factor
uh discounted expectation of future
reward that it's going to get
um in in the environment so that's how
it it
it how q-learning integrates these
experiences to update these q values and
eventually we'll get some and we can
that q
value tells us how good of us uh each
state action
pair is and of course when we're in a
particular state we just we just pick
the
the action the policy is the action that
has the highest q value
so the dirty little secret around
reinforcement learning and something
that really motivates the work that
we're doing here
is that that unlike you and me who are
you know uh
who are wired for pleasure and pain and
who experience the world and
and and and and experience what makes us
happy
you know maybe sunshine makes you happy
and maybe stubbing your toe
makes you unhappy with reinforcement
learning when we're building these rl
agents somebody has to
program the reward function and in
particular it's usually some poor
graduate student that has to take some
sort of complex behavior
and map it into this reward function
which is either
mapping from state to some scalar value
or
a mapping of a state action state
successor state
triple into some sort of scalar value
and that can be really really hard as
we'll discuss and what motivates i think
some of the work that i'm talking about
today
so returning to this this aspiration of
of wanting to be able to
advise instruct and task our rl agents
and actually as an aside maybe you don't
care about this
maybe you you care about artificial
general intelligence there's a lot in
here that is for you as well so so stay
tuned don't stop listening if this is
not your aspiration but this is just
motivating so so there's a big
disconnect between this rs
and imagining sitting on your sofa
talking to your your robot
and so you don't need a phd to raise a
child and you shouldn't need a phd to
task an rl agent and so we should be
able to specify in some sort of more
compelling language
ideally eventually natural language but
for now a formal language
that has a well-defined syntax and and
and uh clearly defined semantics
um is our is our uh language of choice
interestingly there's a very nice paper
that i wanted to give a shout out to by
by uh dulac arnold and his um
co-authors about challenges of real
world rl and i rec it's a quick read i
recommend that you look at it but
some of the challenges that they
identify are indeed
safety constraints reward specifications
and that many of the tasks are partially
observable
and that means that they need some sort
of memory in order to operate in the
environment and what we'll see is that
the
the these formal languages and automata
provide a way of doing that
they also uh he also they the authors
also note that reward specifications
reward functions are underspecified
which can cause problems and
and certainly there's a whole discussion
around ai safety related to that
and also that that we want to be able to
explain our policies and so having
a formal language and and something that
is interpretable also will address
some of those real world challenges but
what i want to focus on today is
two challenges reward specification
which is that it's really hard to define
a reward function for complex tasks
and sample efficiency reinforcement
learning agents might require
billions of interactions with the
environment to learn good policies
so returning to our example let's look
at the some of the types of rewards that
we
reward functions that we might want to
express so here a few that i just
made up imagining my my life sitting on
the sitting on my couch with a
robot to do my doing run the dishwasher
when it's full
or when dishes are needed for the next
meal make sure the bath temperature is
between 38 and 43 celsius immediately
before letting someone enter the bathtub
that would be great for a healthcare
robot or some a robot that is
watching an elderly person or or a child
in your home
do not vacuum while someone is sleeping
in that is in the house is sleeping
or my favorite this is my i'm i've said
this before i'm running this little
reinforcement learning uh
experiment in my house to see how with
two agents who's
and trying to see what their learning
rate is here's my specification
when getting ice cream please open the
freezer take out the ice cream
serve yourself put the ice cream back in
the freezer and close the freezer door
this is a behavior that i want to reward
but i only want to reward it when it's
completed
i don't want to reward it when it's half
done i don't want the freezer to be left
open
in fact that would be something that i
would would want to penalize heavily and
so
so this what you'll notice about all of
these rewards
is that they're temporarily extended
they're conditional
and they're quite rich in terms of their
syntax and yet we have to write those
things as a mapping
r of s or r s a s prime
so what we're going to appeal to and
what we've done in in some of our work
is to appeal to linear temporal logic
which is which is of course
a propositional modal logic with
temporal um modalities
that talk about properties of traces
properties of
of traces over time that are either
interpreted over finite
or infinite traces and and i
i think many of the people who are here
listening to this talk
are familiar with ltl but but um just to
to again uh and you'll see it in a
minute in some examples but it has
the basic logical connectives that we
have and or not
and of course we can define implication
from there it also has these
special modal operators uh
circle um phi is is next
week next until and we can define
these very powerful operators eventually
always
and release and of course linear
temporal logic is used very commonly
in verification and and in synthesis
and and a variety of other tasks and
we're going to appeal to it here
um and if you're not familiar with ltl
and i think everyone here probably is
an important property of ltl is that
certain so
that ltl can be transformed into
automata um different types of automata
sometimes uh deterministic sometimes
non-deterministic sometimes bookie
automata
depending upon the variant of linear
temporal logic that we're talking about
and
i i want you to remember this point
because i'm going to return to it later
so going back to our examples and just
to give a flavor for those who are less
familiar with ltl
i might write do not vacuum while
someone is sleeping is always not
vacuum and sleeping and i might write my
exam my ice cream example is
always get ice cream and plies
eventually open the freezer and next
eventually remove the ice cream from the
freezer and next
serve the ice cream and so on again a
temporary extended formula that is only
going to receive reward
when that full property on interpreted
over a trace
is satisfied so how do we communicate
this to a reinforcement learning agent
when we've got that narrow signal that r
of s
that's what i'm going to talk about in
the rest of the talk so again
the challenges are reward specification
um how we specify these functions and
also sample efficiency because
many of these temporally extended
rewards if we only get a reward at the
end we're doing a lot we're
trying to learn a very complex pattern
that leads to a reward and we need
billions and billions of interactions in
order to ever get those rewards
or ever ever be successful at learning
so throughout this talk i'm going to
give up i'm going to use a very simple
running example it's an office world
domain
where we have four different locations a
b
c and d we have two coffee stations
designated by the coffee cups we have a
mail room
designated by the envelope and we also
have an office designated by this little
o
and for starters our task is going to be
to visit a b c
and d in that order as a simple
sequential task
but but what i'm going to show you later
are some other tasks in this
environment oh yes i should also mention
mention that these little stars are
furniture or fragile things that we do
not want to bump into
so this uh these look like toy problems
and certainly they're easy problems
for us to to describe but they do
challenge state-of-the-art
reinforcement learning techniques as i
will show you in our experiments later
on
so here's an interesting observation as
i alluded to
in in talking about our poor graduate
students it's really
important to note that someone always
has to program the reward function and
they typically do it in
in python so for for our task of
visiting a b
c and d we might write some python code
that looks like the code on the right
um and this is true even when we have a
robot operating in the environment
because although the robot is operating
in the environment rather than in a
simulated environment
it still does not know what
reward-worthy behavior is because it has
no no no signal for that
so the and again as we see and if we
perform this
the reward function is a black box it's
just part of the environment so as the
agent moves in the world and our agent
is this little
purple triangle the agent might go to up
and it tells and the the reward function
takes its state
and returns a reward of zero it might go
uh right
and so on and so forth and it's just
really this black box
so one of the simple and most important
ideas behind our work
is that that that um we should give
the agent access to the reward function
somebody has to program the
reward function it's not top secret we
know what it is
so why not take that reward function and
give it to the
the reinforcement learning agent so that
it can learn more quickly
and indeed so that it can exploit reward
function structure in learning
and that's what i'm going to talk to you
about and that's where the use of formal
language
and automata which is structured by its
syntax
has really paid off in terms of of
learning
and sample efficiency so here we go so
looking at our running example the agent
can exploit the structure
in the reward function in order to learn
and so what we're actually going to do
is
is instead of having the reward function
on the right as it is here in
terms in this black box we're going to
decouple the transition and the reward
function
and we're going to give the reward
function to the agent
so this is what i'm going to talk about
in the next rest of the talk
i'm going to talk about this notion of
reward machines which is an autonomous
base
representation of reward functions i'm
going to tell you how we can exploit
that reward machine structure and
learning
show you some experiments and then at
the end i'm going to talk to you about
different ways in which we can
create reward machines besides the the
obvious way of just
writing the autonomous structure
yourself so reward machines so we're
going to define a reward function using
a reward machine
and we're going to because um you know
the premise at least at the outset is
that
that a human is going to write this we
need a human interpretable vocabulary
here in our example the vocabulary p is
going to be
coffee the the coffee stations the
um the the mailroom the office
the furniture and a b c t that's our
vocabulary over which we're going to
construct this reward machine but it's
going to be
an automata-like structure and
so the vocabulary can comprise human
interpretable events or properties
realized via detectors
over the environment state or it can
conceivably be learned and i'll return
to that discussion at the end but
but for a human being we want it to be
something that the human can
can talk about so here's our reward
machine pictorially
it's comprised of a finite set of states
here for
for our patrolling task u 0 u1 u2 u3
on an initial state u0 a set of
transitions
that are labeled by a logical condition
or a guard
here you know a comma and and as well as
two things
the label is is this logical condition
which is an arbitrary logical formula
as well as a reward function and here in
these examples the reward functions are
just scalar values
a constant but they could be in in its
most generality it could be an actual
reward
another function so a simple reward
function is just a mealy machine
and the one displayed here over the
inputs of
the of the various truth assignments of
these propositions
and the alphabet is a set of markovian
reward functions
more generally we've got you know nice
more for those who are interested in a
precise definition
we've had several more precise
definitions that have evolved over time
in our in our um uh in our work
and i would recommend we have a journal
paper that's coming out this is from
that journal paper
um but but uh and it captures this sort
of general notion that a reward machine
is comprised of a tuple that has
these these states
an initial state a terminating
a finite set of terminal states which
can be the empty set if we want
this reward machine to operate into
perpetuity to have no terminal
terminal state and then two different
functions of delta u
which is the state transition function
which maps you
to another state in in that reward
function structure
reward machine structure or to recognize
the terminal state
as well as this reward function which
maps your position in the reward machine
to uh another to some sort of complex
reward function
and again the reward machine that i the
simple reward machine that i
showed you in my picture was just one
that maps to a scalar value the maps to
the reals
as a function of two to the p as opposed
to mapping to
a family of different reward functions
so returning to our our reward machines
we can see what happens in action
using this reward machine and again
watch the little agent
in who's the purple triangle down here
we the agent
moves and we're in u0 the agent moves
it it tells the reward function where it
is
and the road function returns
transitions in the reward machine
and returns some sort of reward and here
we got a reward of zero
now the agent goes to a we see that a
actually satisfies the logical condition
on the first edge between u0 and u1
so the the reward machine is actually it
tells the reward
machine the agent tells reward machine
what it's the action that it's performed
and uh we transition um
to u1 and but we still get no reward we
still get a reward of zero
and on and on we go moving around
and transitioning through you can see
the the agent moving through the space
and transitioning within the reward
machine
it's now in state three so it which
remembers that it's gotten from a
it's gone to a it's gone to b it's gone
to c it's now in this
u3 and it's but but d is not true it has
not yet reached d
and when it finally reaches d it
uh it transitions back to u0 and gets a
reward of one
so the reward machine is actually
keeping track of of this reward function
for us
and and and yet the individual rewards
in here are markovian
we can define all sorts of other reward
machines delivered to
the coffee to the office while avoiding
furniture again
um when we were in you we start a new
zero when we've gone to the coffee
machine and we haven't hit any furniture
we get a reward of zero and when we
subsequently after having gotten coffee
go to the office we we transition to you
three
and get that reward of one if at any
point in time we hit the furniture
we we transition to a sink state which
we stay in in perpetuity where we get a
reward of zero
similarly we can deliver coffee and mail
to the office and of course we haven't
stipulated what order we want to do it
in so it could be
that we we um get the coffee and then
and the mail and then go to the office
or we can get the mail and then the
coffee and then go to the office
and both of those those pathways are
captured
within our reward machine structure
so now that you've got some sense of
what a reward machine looks like
and and it's its formal structure i want
to talk to you very importantly about
how we can actually
exploit that reward machine structure in
learning
and i'm going to talk to you about it in
the context of of three
of five different approaches
three of them were things that we
considered to be baselines but they were
all of our creation
and then two more that that showcase
special purpose algorithms that we were
using
that really exploit the reward machine
structure that we have
um embodied in our reward machines
so the first baseline which is our
baseline is
is the q learning baseline and again i
explained q learning to you previously
um an important thing to to observe is
uh that a reward machine may define a
non-markovian
reward function sorry about that um and
and i that's exemplified by the the
picture that you can see here so if my
little
agent uh the triangle here is
is uh adjacent to d
but it's uh and it goes to d then then
what
the reward that it's going to get is
going to be different depending upon
its history so the reward function is
actually non-markovian
if it's gone to abc already and then it
goes to d
from that square it will get a reward of
one but otherwise if it hasn't
passed through abc first it'll get a
reward of zero so let's see what that
looks like if it just
if it was in u1 and it just moved to d
it's going to stay in u1
and get a reward of zero whereas if it
was in
u3 which meant that it had passed
through a it had passed through b
it and it already passed through c and
it moved from that square to the right
uh and it was in u3 then it would get
a reward of one so different same move
different different reward and again
these reward functions are non-markovian
so the obvious baseline to do is just to
do this obvious cross product
so we're going to cross product the the
um the state of the system with the the
reward machine
and we're going to be able to to try to
do basic q learning with that baseline
and um we're going to use q learning on
the resulting mdp that is the cross
product
the second thing that we wanted to try
was something called hierarchical
reinforcement learning
which is abbreviated to hrl hierarchical
reinforcement learning
uh learns a set of of options
and and a meta controller and the
options are basically
like macro actions or or pre pre-learned
um
or learned uh sub-policies that can be
composed together
in order to perform tasks in in a
hierarchical manner as
alluded to by the by the um by the name
so um in this context what we're going
to do is we're going to learn one
option policy for each proposition
mentioned in the reward machine
so since the reward machine refers to a
b c and d
we're going to learn a policy pi a for
a mapping from any state to to get to
to um with the objective of getting two
to
a pi b pi c
and pi d and then what we're going to do
is we're going to
optimize which pi i we're going to apply
to satisfy
to satisfy our objective ideally
optimally
the third um and and so you can see here
the way that
hierarchical hrl works is that in
addition to having these policies these
options that it learns pi a
pi b pi c and pi d it also has to learn
a better controller
so it's simultaneously going to learn
how to use each of the option policies
taking input from both the reward
machine and from the
the the environment to learn a good meta
controller
that's option two our our third option
is is hierarchical reinforcement
learning with
uh reward machine based pruning and the
simple observation here is that you know
our reward machine
tells us by virtue of what state it's in
use 0 u1 u2 or u3
which policy it should be applying at
that state so if we actually use the
state of the reward machine
to better inform the meta controller
then we can actually
prune policies that are not relevant at
a particular time
so for example when we're in u0 we know
that the first thing we have to do is
get to a
and so we should be applying the pi a
policy when we're at u1 we should be
applying the pi v policy and so on
so we use we learn a policy using this
pruning
um from our reward machine structure
and an interesting thing about reward
machines are about hierarchical
reinforcement learning that i wanted to
mention to you
as a sidebar is that hierarchical
reinforcement learning
approaches find locally optimal
solutions because they are myopic
because they are
optimizing each of those policies in
isolation the policy to get to a the
policy to get to b the policy to get to
see
it isn't necessarily that even though
those individual policies are optimal
they may not be optimal in aggregate and
a great um
example of that is the example that i
have here which is
is the delivering coffee to the office
example
so if i want to deliver coffee to the
office you can see the office here in
sdo we can we
we can go to either one coffee station
or another
and our system will will choose which
one to go to
so in hierarchical reinforcement
learning um this is
this is the this first um policy
this first path which i've shown you is
is the optimal policy it takes 10 steps
to get
to um or 13 steps excuse me to get to
uh to the office um after having
uh picked up the coffee uh but what's
interesting about this
is that it to get from a to the coffee
machine
is actually 10 steps whereas the other
pathway
which is uh which goes through this
other coffee station
is one two three four five six
seven i think eight steps and and which
is and so the optimal policy to get to
coffee if you look at it myopically is
to go to this coffee station
but then having committed to that coffee
station um
unfortunately there's a very long
pathway to get to the office
unfortunately
hrl will always take the optimal um
the the locally optimal step um and and
so
it will choose this longer pathway to
get um to get to the
uh to to realize this task and you'll
see this borne out in some of our
results
in contrast q learning actually
preserves optimality
so our fourth uh algorithm which is our
qrm algorithm that i want to talk to you
about is the algorithm that we created
in order to exploit the reward machine
structure
to learn more efficiently and um
just a a heads up i didn't create new
slides but we do have a journal paper
coming out
where we have a variant of qrm called
crm which stands for counterfactual
reward machines
which is a a new improved version of qrm
that actually doesn't produce separate
policies that produces one large policy
which we believe is going to be better
for generalization
and you can see that paper if you're
interested in this but but the the
results are
are as good and and better than the qrm
results in all cases
so here's the way that qrm works
remember uh what we want to do is we're
going to the first step is that we're
going to learn
one policy or q value per
state in the reward machine so a q value
for u0
a q value for a q value for u1 for u2
and for u3 then we're going to select
actions using the policy of the current
reward machine so when we're in u0
we're going to use the policy or the
cube um informed by the q function that
we've learned for
for q0 when we're in u1 we're going to
learn the the q function for
you for for being in state u1
and so on u0 q0 u1
q1 and so on and then but but
the the most important thing that we're
going to do and i think this is the
power of our learning
is that we're going to use off policy
learning to reuse experiences to update
all of our q
value value functions simultaneously
it's really a form of counter factual
reasoning and i'm going to uh
elaborate upon this um in the slides
that follow but this
is the secret sauce or one of the secret
sauces that makes
our our learning so effective because
we're getting multiple by
by decomposing our reward function into
um into a bunch of different markovian
reward functions
of separate reward functions or by
making a
markovian decomposition excuse me of
this reward function
and by exploiting this reward machine
structure we're able to learn
different piece even though we're not at
one particular state in the the reward
machine we can learn and update our q
values for
the all the different um states
simultaneously by a form of counter
factual reasoning
so here we go let's say we're in u0 and
we're going to
um and we're going to move we can see
where
we're going to update each q value as if
the reward machine was in each of the
corresponding states so even though
we're actually in u0
we're going to pretend that we're in
each of these u1 u2 u
and u3 and update all of the
corresponding states so let's see what
that looks for
so if we take an action and and uh we
move
and we get a reward and we're and we're
in u0 then we're going to get a reward
of use
of zero and the update of our q function
uh our quality of that state and that
action
is going to be zero which is the reward
we got plus the
the discounted um future award that
we're going that we expect to get
um being in uh for q0
if we are instead in u1 we're going to
do a similar sort of where and we move
to to d
to that position uh we're similarly
going to get a reward of 0 and we're
going to update
um again we're going to stay in in u1
and we're going to uh
our expected future reward is going to
be with respect to q1
when we're in uh u2 similarly uh we're
going to
get a reward of zero and we're going to
update the the expected future reward
um with respect to being in u2
and finally this is the one that's
different um when we're
counterfactually you know we're
imagining this in our mind if we had
been in u3 instead
and we had performed this action of
moving to d
what would have happened is that we
would have transitioned in the reward
machine
from u3 to u0 and we would have gotten a
reward of one
and the update therefore for this
particular state
q3 is that we're going to get a reward
of one
and we're going to add that to our
discounted expected future
award which is going to be with respect
to q0
um not with respect to because we've
moved um within the reward machine
so this is how we're learning using this
reward machine and this is how we're
doing
this it's a form of counter factual
reasoning so for every move we make we
just move that one spot from to the
right that a that we see in our office
diagram we're able to get the a huge
bang for our buck because we can counter
factually
imagine that we were in these other
states within our reward machine and
update the experiences as if we were in
that state instead
so um recall we we had these
these different um techniques that i
outlined the last one i've just
explained four to you
the last thing i want to explain is is
um qrm this algorithm that i just told
you about
with reward shaping so some of you may
know something about reward shaping
others don't one of the things that i
alluded to at the beginning
was that a huge problem with sample
efficiency a huge problem with with
reinforcement learning is that a lot of
the time there's no signal
there's no reward so so um the agent
will be
moving around and and trying to figure
out what to do and it will get
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero and
that can be very problematic
and and cause it to have to have a lot
of um
a lot of experiences in order to learn
the function and indeed
what i did not mention previously is
that it q
learning is guaranteed to converge to
the optimal policy
with tabular learning when we're not
using any sort of a function
approximation
and that's a really important step
because you can see how
because eventually it will learn the
optimal policy it just needs a lot of
um of samples so the the idea behind
reward shaping is a very intuitive one
if you imagine you're going to perform
this long arduous journey at the end
you're going to get a chocolate chip
cookie
then instead what you're going to do is
something like hansel and gretel
reward shaping takes that cookie and
sort of spreads it
along the path um so that so that the
cumulative reward you get in the end is
the same but it's it's
shaping the reward function in a way
that gives you some
intermediate um reward and this notion
of reward shaping is one that's very
popular in reinforcement learning it was
uh i believe first proposed by andrew
ing harada and stuart russell
in 1999 i think that's the earliest
citation
but it's based on this notion of having
a defining a potential function
and so the the the reward function that
you have this r
s a s prime or r s um is augmented with
with this you know adding and and then
deleting of these this the this uh
extra cookie that you've spread that
that uh
allows for a shaping of the reward so
the int the important thing about reward
shaping is that
um it does not compromise your ability
to still learn the optimal policy
and it learns it more quickly so we're
guaranteed that the found policies are
still optimal
with respect to the original unshaped
reward function so that's a very
powerful property and one that that ing
and
russell showed so here's an example
of our coffee delivery reward machine
which we saw before
and in red what you'll see is is the
augmentation
of those um those reward uh
those rewards those scalar rewards that
we were getting uh that are the labels
for our
our edges augmented with reward shaping
and and the interesting thing was that
the way that we did reward shaping as
our as described in hki 19 paper
was that we basically did value
iteration over the reward machine
in order to figure out what that reward
shaping was and then we applied that
and then we applied qrm to the
the shaped reward machine so we've taken
our original reward machine and we've
just changed around the numbers
a little bit so um
a nice thing and again i alluded to this
that q learning
preserves in in the tabular case has
optimality guarantees it's guaranteed to
converge to the optimal policy in the
limit
and so q both the application of our two
algorithms qrm
and qrm with reward shaping both um
preserve that that those optimality
guarantees for us which is very nice
so now i've told you about um defining
what a reward machine is an automatic
structure
if you go back to the slide with the
reward shaping so
it seems that now you have rewards both
on the states and on the
on the actions right and yeah that's
right
how should i read this so as let us say
if you started the initial statement
with the arrow
then every time you take an edge you get
the corresponding reward on the edge
but then do you also get a penalty for
being in that state so how do you yes
that's right
you get a penalty so that so that so
that it incents you to
to uh to to move on it didn't sense you
not to stay in that state
i see okay okay thanks
thanks okay
so so uh those were our yeah so now i'm
going to
thank you for the question um so now
we're going to uh
go on to our experiments and to see how
this work has worked and for us in
practice
and the experiments were comprised of
two domains with a discrete actions
and state space and one domain with a
continuous state space a deep learning
um space and in our our journal paper we
have
um some nice uh experiments with half
cheetah as well
and we've integrated our our code with
the with open ai gym
so that's something else for um for
people to look at if they're they're
interested but i don't i didn't uh have
those results here
the um again we testified tested all
five approaches that i've just discussed
with you
and at the table at the bottom provides
a little bit of a summary so we've got
qrm hierarchical reinforcement learning
hierarchical reinforcement learning
where we were doing that reward machine
pruning
of the policies um qrm which was our
our uh out cue learning algorithm that
exploited
um the the reward machine structure by
doing off policy learning
and then qrm with reward shaping and
again
as we see in the tabular case with these
discrete domains
optimality is preserved with q learning
and with our two
qrm based algorithms and reward shaping
and
and indeed our um our by our
autonomous structure our reward machine
structure does provide for a
decomposition
as does hierarchical reinforcement
learning the original q-learning
algorithm does not
so we can see those two things
influencing what we did
and so here's our example again where
we're in this office world setting
um we've got in the the graph that
you're about to see
on the x-axis the horizontal axis we
have the number of training steps
and it goes up to 50 000. on the y-axis
the vertical axis
we have the normalized discounted reward
so the reward the optimal reward is
always one
we just normalized it for comparison
purposes and
um you can see the legend on the
right-hand side uh all of the
the four first algorithms are here i'm
going to show you the reward shaping
algorithms afterwards
so here we go um our algorithm our qrm
algorithm is the the red um is the red
line and we can see that it very quickly
um in about fifteen thousand training
steps
or actually maybe thirteen thousand
training steps it hit the optimal
policy and converge to it both
hierarchical reinforcement learning with
reward with reward machine pruning which
is the
the the light blue line and just
hierarchical
reinforcement learning both did quite
well you can see the blue
the the the one with the the reward
machine pruning
also learned quite quickly but they
plateau to a sub-optimal
um solution um in some of our examples
we had four tasks and we did 30
independent trials
per task um and whereas the q learning
the blue the the sort of royal blue line
that that is at the bottom which is
performing
least well um did make some progress but
but again it and it achieved the state
um that
the hrl achieved and eventually with
enough
samples that q learning algorithm that
royal blue line
will eventually get to one but this
speaks to the
the gain and sample complexity from
using our qrm algorithm because
because uh compared to q learning
without that reward machine
function structure we did a second set
of
discrete there's another question if i
may interrupt you yeah
yeah it's from one of uh it's from
kishore so it says it appears that the
shaped rewards are sparse
in the sense that the agent is rewarded
for a subtask only at the end of the
subtask
and in the meantime receiving constant
rewards
is this sufficient in environments with
continuous states and actions
so um yeah so so if you don't mind i'll
post
there's no reward shaping in these
results and i'm going to get to the
reward shaping in a minute so so maybe
i'll i'll show you the reward machine
results
and then i will answer that question and
and i think that the the person who
asked the question will
like to see the the graphs as well so so
um
yeah good so so we're still in tabular
domain so we're not using function
approximation yet
and we did some experiments on these
these minecraft
like domains uh a craft world um
where we had 10 tasks over 10 random
maps three independent trials per
combination
some of the tasks were similar to the
ones that jacob andreas had used in his
icml
2017 paper and again you know
making you know you you collect ore and
you
you collect wood and you make an axe or
you you
so our little agent luigi is moving
around in this environment
making different things and again um we
have the same graph where we have the
normal
we have the number of training steps on
the x-axis up to 10 to the sixth
so so many more training steps and on
the
vertical y-axis we have the normalized
discounted reward
and it goes to again to one same four of
our first approaches not the reward
shaping approach yet
and we can again see the the our uh
qrm algorithm which is the red um line
uh converges reasonably quickly with far
more sample efficiently
to the optimal uh reward
whereas uh hrl hierarchical
reinforcement learning with reward
machines which is the the powder blue
again um converts converges quite
quickly as well
but it converges to this sub-optimal
policy because of the
because of this myopic property that
that hrl has
and then the other hrl that doesn't use
the reward machine pruning
takes longer to learn but but it
actually gets to a higher policy
a higher property and i'm not quite sure
why that is i guess it's they're both
within the noise of each other so
so maybe that speaks to to some
optimizations and some of the work
what's notable and what you may or may
not see
is the blue line that is right on the
the um
x axis at the bottom that's q learning
q learning uh after 10 to the six
experiments could not
could not solve these problems at all
which speaks to to you know the the gain
that we get from the decomposition
of the the reward structure um both with
hierarchical reinforcement learning and
also with our reward machine structure
because that blue line
given you know as we extrapolate out to
the right given enough samples that blue
line will converge to one
and given enough samples it's guaranteed
to do so and it just speaks to the the
problem with sparse rewards
so with function approximation again on
our first four algorithms
um we we did we replaced q learning with
double dqm these were experiments that
were done
in in um uh 20 2018
or and so um and we've updated them in
our qrm
in our cr our journal paper but but you
can see that
now that we're doing function
approximation we've lost our optimality
guarantees but we still have some of the
decomposition
that speaks to why we're doing so well
so the the experiments that we were
doing were in something called the water
world domain
which is where the agent now is this
white cue ball or billiard ball
and it's moving around in this and it's
controllable and it's moving around in
an environment where there are
different colored balls that are
bouncing off of the uh that have
you know particular movement and speed
and that are bouncing off of the walls
in
in different ways according you know to
laws of physics
and and the types of tasks that we gave
to to our agent were things like
um never hit a pink ball and always hit
a green ball and then uh
and then a yellow ball or hit two yellow
balls and then a blue ball
so so sort of ordering types of
constraints
that that the agent had to control
itself in order to learn how to perform
and again we did 10 tasks over 10 random
maps three independent trials per
combination
and these were our results and again um
double dqn which was was an excellent
you know
cubase q learning algorithm for deep
learning um is performing very poorly
you can see it at the bottom
the two heart uh deep hierarchical
reinforcement learning algorithms are
are performing better again the one with
the reward machine
um pruning is again still performing
better and you can see that that our
deep um qrm algorithm uh really
really rocked it so um that was that was
really gratifying to
a gratifying endorsement i think of the
approach
so now we're at the reward machine slide
so let me just present the results and
then i'll and then i will
i will take the um the question from the
audience which is
which is that when we added so on these
graphs we have the same x and y
axis uh training steps on the x-axis and
and
uh normalized reward on the y-axis
and um we the the plots that i'm showing
you are for q-learning in blue
qrm which is what we previously our
previous winner
and now in black and red and now in
black qrm
augmented with reward shaping and what
you'll see in the first two
graphs on the left you'll see that the
when we added reward shaping
we actually did a little better we
converge to an optimal policy
more quickly because of that
intermediate guidance that we were
getting from the reward shaping
as opposed to these tasks and all the
tasks i showed you
there was some sort of temporally
extended thing that had to occur
and we were only giving reward at the
end of the task
whereas with the reward shaping we were
giving some intermediate reward
as as uh illustrated so interestingly
and perhaps precisely to the
um to the comment of the um
of the person who asked the question we
can see that in the continuous domain
the reward shaping did not do as well it
did not help qrm it actually hindered it
and so now with that perfect setup maybe
you can um
uh revic maybe you can ask the question
again and maybe this gives you the
answer which is probably yes
so
uh kishore do you want to ask a question
yourself so yes
yeah so yeah so my question was so
i mean even with with or without reward
shaping if you have
constant rewards on the edges as opposed
to reward functions like i think you
presented both formulas
so if you have constant reward functions
on the edges
of the reward machine how well does that
work in
continuous scenarios because i can
imagine you saying go get
coffee and let's say the same office
world domain is continuous no
and you are only rewarded when you
actually kept the coffee
and i imagine even the sub task is
somewhat hard if
if you have sparse rewards so i just
wanted to know if
uh you are forced to give continuous
towards there and
uh yeah i mean and whether this reward
shipping strategy would work there
at all right yeah i mean that i think is
sort of answered by the plot
yeah so it's answered by the plot
exactly um um
which so i thought you would be happy to
see that that answers your question but
but
certainly in continuous i mean the
beauty of the reward machine is that in
the in the
when you're not using simple reward
machines when you can actually have a
the the label can be a reward a function
and and in continuous domains i think
that's for many things i think that's an
effective thing to do because it
and it allows you in some way to sort of
to almost better shape the
it's it's it it in and of itself do you
know sort of addresses this this
issue with with um having having these
big jumps from
here from zero to one in terms of the
reward but but
allowing you to tailor the reward in in
a particular way relative to the the
specific shape
and and if if word reward
shaping was combined with that type of a
reward function i think it would be even
more
powerful
okay thanks yeah thanks good question
thank you
so um the last thing i wanted to talk
about was creating reward machines
um so we've we've seen that that that
you know i talked about linear temporal
logic a little bit at the beginning and
motivated the use of formal languages
but but throughout this talk i've been
talking about using this automative
structure which is a reward machine in
order to
to specify reward functions so let's now
return to the to how we might go about
creating reward machines
so where do these reward machines come
from we can specify a reward machine
directly
or we can actually uh generate
automatically generate
a reward machine via translation from a
specification in some sort of other
language
that's one way we can do it we can also
generate a reward machine from some sort
of a high-level goal specification
and then a third way that we can do it
is that we can actually learn reward
machines and i'm going to take a little
bit of time to to sort of
overview each of these three approaches
we've done work on all of these
and i'm not going to talk about them in
too much detail but i just want to give
you a heads up so that if you are
interested in this
um you can look a little bit further
so um reward specifications you know
like like any specification language
and i'm sure we those of us who who who
work in
in model based domains know this you
know one size do not does not fit all
it's and just as one programming
language does not fit all
sometimes a regular language is better
sometimes something like
uh linear temporal logic is a better
language for specifying things sometimes
and and and some people just like to
write automata other people it doesn't
make sense at all
so you do not need to specify reward
machines directly in order to use reward
machines
reward machines are a form of melee
machine at least in the in the simple
case of
a more machine and in the more
complicated case um and we can specify
reward worthy behavior
in any formal language that is
translatable to a finite state
automaton or or you know in the case of
if we make f's
infinite uh abuja automaton so
um and again we can there's a picture of
nem chomsky
to who did this audience should be well
known but of course he's famous or
infamous
to dever his political views as well to
the rest of the world but of course
through this this basic relationship
that has already been established but
that any regular language can be um
translated into a finite state
autonomous so too
can we translate any sort of regular
language
and a subset of linear temporal logic
into a reward machine
and we had a paper that talked a little
bit about that so
we view reward machines it can sort of
serve as a lingua franca
or a normal form representation for
reward functions
that that so we can specify in a number
of different languages
um where the the translation to an a a
finite state automata is understood
again a subset of linear temporal logic
but but or linear temporal logic
interpreted over finite states but and
many other regular
types of languages and then translates
translate those automatically into a
reward machine
and the beauty of using the reward
machine as a normal form is that that if
you wanted to use ltl directly or you
wanted to use some sort of other regular
language but you wanted to use
exploit function structure and learning
you'd have to
do something like qrm for ltl and qrm
for
ldl or qrm for for something like this
whereas
when we use the automata structure it's
a normal form structure and
anybody's language anybody's algorithms
the one that we created or hopefully
some future ones that other people
create can all be used
with this sort of normal form structure
um
we've actually built a tool i think i
forgot to to add it to my slides that
does some of that translation
um it's a system called flat that i uh
flat the transmographer
that does some of that that compilation
for us but that's
that's one way in which we can we can
construct reward machines
so that's good to remember the second
piece of work that we've done is to use
symbolic planners to generate reward
reward machines and let me just motivate
this for you so so i'm i come from
uh among i wear many different hats but
one of my hats is that i've done a lot
of work
in symbolic ai planning where we have
you know either goal state high level
goal states or temporally extended goal
states you know think about
your grandmother with their robot at
home wanting to tell the
the robot to you know get me my
um get me my glasses from the bedroom
um you know your grandmother shouldn't
have to
to um to generate a reward machine
and yet if if just given that one task
it's very it's going to be very sparse
and so what we'd like to be able to do
is generate have a high level planner
that can generate instructions for the
robot
to tell it some guide points or
waypoints that would provide a temporary
extended or richer reward function
structure that the agent could use and
in order
maybe with with um with policies that is
already learned
or to adapt in order to to learn reward
behavior so what we did though was to
use symbolic planning
to with these high level goals in a high
level very high level model of the
under model of the world take these
symbolic plan these
these final state goals generate plans
use those symbolic plans
uh in a as a part of a reward to
populate a reward machine
and then um to to use uh hierarchical
reinforcement learning
or some sort of other um approach in
order to
to learn and that's described it it's
probably the best references in icaps 20
paper
by elena's uh era who's one of my
graduate students but it won a best
paper awarded a workshop
at europe's recently which was really
nice for the students the second student
was an undergraduate
so the last thing i wanted to talk about
and then i'm almost done because i know
we're getting close to one and i want to
leave time for for other people
is to talk a little bit about this
interesting correspondence between
partial observability
memory and and markovian representation
so you'll remember the beginning of the
the talk that that i i
referred to this dudlock arnold paper
and and talking about how
one of the challenges to reward to to
reinforcement learning in practice
is that most environments are partially
partially observable and if you think
about even just a vision environment you
know i'm
i'm driving my car and and as as with
each frame my
my viewpoint my my state of the world as
is
is very different from a high level and
if i turn a corner then
everything that i saw on the previous
road is is gone from my
my current state because my current
state is defined by by what i see right
now
so so we either have to construct a
belief state which is what we typically
do with palm dps
but but but the or but we can think
about the state as being you know the
his
encoded by the history of states and
actions that we perform
so one of the things that we did in
europe's 19 paper is to try to learn
reward machines for partially observable
environments
so again we were still given a
vocabulary
um we didn't learn the vocabulary from
scratch but we learned
uh how to reward machines for partially
observable environments and this speaks
to many things how to do partially
observable rl
but also how to use a reward machine as
memory in a partially observable
environment
so what i want to do is describe the the
problem to you
and then um and then describe the
solution
so the problem this is a very simple
picture this picture on the left
it's it's uh um
three rooms a blue room a yellow room
and what i'll call a red room it's sort
of pinky
and then that green that purple triangle
is our agent
but unfortunately as we see on the right
the agent can
only see in the room that it's in either
the corridor
uh when it's in the corridors it can't
see what's in any of the rooms so it's
partially observable it has to go into
the corridor or into the rooms to see
what's in there
and in this little toy example that i
have there's a button
in the yellow room and when the agent
presses the button
a cookie appears magically either in the
blue room or in the red room
you know with randomly
and the agent needs to when it's in that
at that t junction exactly where it is
right now it has to learn what to do
and of course what it does the optimal
behavior when it's in that
position depends on what it's done
before it depends on what it's done in
the past because it can't see
um it needs to remember and so what what
happens is that when it's
when it's in that position and it's the
beginning it needs to go up to the
the yellow room and press the button
when it's press the button and it gets
back to that position
if if it hasn't eaten a cookie then it
needs to go to one of the rooms
look for a cookie if they find a cookie
it needs to eat the cookie and then when
it gets back to that position
it needs to go back and press the button
again or if it
went to one of the rooms the red room or
the blue room and didn't find a cookie
then it needs to remember that it's
pressed the button gone to one of the
rooms not found a cookie and that it
needs to go to the other room so
same spot you know that same position
within that t
junction but but depending upon what
it's done in the past
it needs to remember what it needs to do
and so our task
here that we were trying to address and
we had uh was to
um to try to learn a reward machine that
would help us to solve this problem
so the assumption that we want to find a
policy that maximizes the
external reward given by a partially
observable environment our assumption is
the agent has a set of high-level binary
classifiers or event detectors so that
we know when the button's been pushed we
know when they're cookies
but we don't know where they are and the
key insight was that we were going to
learn in a reward machine such that its
external state
could be effectively used as external
memory by the agent to solve the task
so this speaks to another role that our
automata are playing
as well as our ability to learn these
automata and we learn these automata
through discrete optimization
via taboo search and i just want to
say before before i go and show you the
reward machine that we learned that
these
toy problems and they do look like such
simple problems
in 2019 could not be solved by
state-of-the-art deep learning
techniques such as a3c ppo and acer
using lstms these are really hard
problems because of this problem with
memory
and how far back you need to remember
and and what you need to remember
so here is the reward machine that you
learned and actually you can if you
stare at it
you know there are a couple of great
things about it it's not just that we
learned this and that it really helped
in
in solving the problem as i'll show you
on the next slide but it's also that
it's interpretable in a way
so if you if you look here when you're
in u0
you stay in u0 until you go to the
yellow room and press the button
and when you go to the yellow room and
you press a button you transition to u1
getting a reward of zero um when you
again
when you're in u1 if you go to the
uh blue room and there's a cookie in the
blue room
then you go to u3 if you go to the
blue room and then there's no cookie uh
in that room then you'd go to u2 and so
on
and um eventually when you you eat the
cookie which is this
um black and white cookie you get a
reward of one and you go back to zero so
this is
you know i um we've we've represented
we've got some other work where we use
these automata to to
to structure our understanding of of
these classifiers that we're learning
um using automata and and i think
they're reasonably
i find them intuitive to look at but you
can extract different explanations from
them
so here are our results using lrm
learning reward machines
again same training steps on the x-axis
reward on the
y-axis normalized we have
our two algorithms are the ones that are
doing well the green line is optimal
and the other flat lined at the bottom
are all of these
circa 2019 um uh state-of-the-art deep
learning algorithms that are just
flatlining on this problem
however using learning reward machines
with either double dqn or learning
reward machines
with which is blue or learning reward
whoops learning reward machines with
with qrm with deep qrm
we see that we converge to to optimal
quite quickly so it really does
speak to the the strength of these
techniques
so that's it i'm almost done i'm just
going to recap quickly
i motivated this talk by talking about
how do we advise instruct task and
impart knowledge to our reinforcement
learning agents
and indeed what we learned is that we
can exploit the alphabet and structure
of language to help reinforcement
learning agents learn and think you know
a long-term aspiration for me is to use
natural language
but i think that these structured
languages and the ability to write
function structures in a very structured
way
and exploit those in our learning is is
incredibly promising and
and uh something that i hope and that
many other people are
looking at now as well so our key
insight
in addition to just using these automata
was to reveal the reward function to the
agent
because somebody's got to program it
anyways we
we talked about um what a reward machine
was we talked about
this qrm algorithm we talked about qrm
with
word shaping we talked about translating
reward machines from other languages to
generate those reward machine
specifications
we talked about learning reward machines
in partially observable environments and
i showed you
at least in passing i mentioned this
notion of being able to task
a reinforcement learning agent by giving
it a high level goal
having the agent use symbolic planning
to generate a plan
and then using that to guide to guide
search
so we got great results in discrete
domains and in continuous domains
we can construct the reward machines
from a different diversity of formal
languages
we can generate them using symbolic
planners and
they can be learned in partially
observable environments to solve hard
problems
we've we've our code is all available
for people to use that's cur you know
that's rodrigo toro carter who's done
almost all of you know all of that i
guess for everything that i'm talking
about today
um there i've these slides i'll just
flip through them quickly but
but if you go to his website or his bit
bucket page where you look at the papers
you'll see the links to the the code um
the
again the the qrm code
has now been um we've updated it with
something called crm we've got a journal
paper that's coming out
and um the code and the paper are
available at rodrigo's website right now
we've got another um paper that's that's
under review where we were generalizing
linear temporal logic
instructions for multitask rl um we've
done some other interesting related work
in the past on on advice based
exploration
in model based rl we've done some work
on non-markovian rewards and mdps and
we've also got some work on
whoops on learning interpretable models
in linear temporal logic
as well as a lot of past work on
planning with formal languages and
automata
both for non-deterministic automata and
finite
lt with using ltl translated to various
types of
automata and interpreted over either
finite or infinite traces
and um also doing preferences as well so
this the work that you see here builds
upon a rich legacy that goes back i
think you know
almost 12 or 14 years so huge
acknowledgements to rodrigo toro carter
his his um collaborators to corin
classen and rick valenzano
as well as various other collaborators
at different times and also a shout out
to alberto camacho who's done a lot of
work with ltl synthesis and ltl planning
and that certainly influenced this work
so
i think that's it so i'm going to stop
sharing now and and
happy to take questions or or release
everybody but thank you very much for
your patience and for listening
thank you very much so let me uh thank
you on behalf of
the entire audience it's a bit difficult
to do the server zoom thank you
if you have a question you can just
unmute yourself and or ask
and ask or um uh you can just write
something on the chat and i can uh call
upon you
uh there is a question from suguman um
i can read this out and in the meantime
i'll uh
enable subwoofers mic so thank you for
the great talk
my question is about the hrl algorithm
is it possible to obtain theoretical
guarantees on how suboptimal the
policies can be
when learnt using hrl
uh there probably is analytically
ah yeah interesting that's a great
question and
a and a and a good and a good problem i
mean you have to understand
the difference between yeah i
yeah i'm not sure whether you can i'm
not sure whether you can
i'd have to think about it a little bit
more
what's your opinion no idea i
i would like to know i mean it's it's
unlike
it's it's unclear to me how hierarchical
approaches
would have any guarantees on them uh
but it feels like for say learning on
complex tasks hierarchical hierarchical
approaches may be better than
simple qrm uh so if we could do
something
that you know gives any kind of
guarantee with hrl
that would be nicer i feel for more
complex tasks
right yeah so it's it's compelling to
think about being able to really
decouple these things and compose them
together and i like you know
i i think one doesn't do one self uh
service in terms of research by being
sort of fixated on one's approach so
hrl has you know great um great
properties associated with it and this
notion of really being able to decompose
into these different options and using
them together is really compelling but
it's
but it's just hard to say how how bad
you know so you go to the worst you do
you
how bad is the worst solution to some
sub step in a in a policy it's hard to
i guess if you could wait how much
influence it would be you might be able
to do something we can talk about it a
little bit more offline but but i i
yeah i i would love to and just the
example you gave right
hr can be myopic at times and what if it
just
because of being myopic what if it just
falls into a very very suboptimal
area right so that's something you want
to be able to avoid but i would love to
continue this conversation afterwards
that's right
and there may you know yeah i have a
couple of comments there maybe some way
to combine the two
um while still even getting more benefit
from the hrl
um yeah thanks thank you for the great
talk i i really enjoyed it
thank you and thanks rupert for
mediating
anna uh hi thanks for the great talk
um my question is also about hpro so i
i'm no expert
at all on deep reinforcement learning
but i i've seen some approaches
and the recent approach i've seen i
think it's from 2019
is where they use this hindsight
experience replay
and it it sounded to me like this
approach could be comparable because
they
especially when they combine it with um
hierarchical
uh erl when they say that high level
agent
defines what the sub goals would be and
the lower
level agent just has to follow this
subcodes
um it sounded to me like this could be
uh compared but i
i would like i would like to hear your
opinion on that
yeah so i guess i have a couple of
different comments one one is that you
know
like her this hindsight experience
replay is exactly like what we're doing
with this off policy learning where
we're sort of getting more juice out of
our
our we're uh out of what we're doing but
you know i think that that
one thing that i find promising is is is
there's a lot of work now in goal
conditioned rl and if
if you can somehow do you know think
about the distribution
of of um if you could do our hrl
if you could do options in a way that
was goal conditioned
and then have different options
predicated on the goal
then you might be able to you might in
some instances be able to
to understand how to make it a little
bit give it a little bit more look ahead
so that it could anticipate gee if i'm
if i'm just going home then then this is
the route i should take but if i'm going
home and i want to stop at the
the bakery on route then then there's
another then
if that's one of my my temporary
extended goal looking forward
then then this is the op this is the the
optim
the the option the way that the option
should should exhibit and so maybe
there's something we can add to our
options to
to make them more um yeah yeah i also
feel like this is what's missing and
also in her
like this this kind of to make these
goals more um
targeted yeah yeah but it's interesting
it's a great question and i i really
like her
the the basic notion you know of skills
and
options and having these these these
abilities but but then being able to
somehow
contextualize them to still get
something that's closer to optimal would
is compelling
but i had the second question if i may
yes
i i was quite curious about this um the
reward structure this reward that home
of them
so my question is whether this
can be easily so especially when you
learn it whether this structure can be
also easily and added new
new states for rewards new
new transitions so whether we can easily
relearn it to adapt to something else
for example if you have another cookie
that appears in a room
and now you have to remember more
yeah so so so what would that involve so
so i mean yeah again we're sort of back
to
to where we were before so so yeah the
it's a question a little bit about
generalization and
and about the decomposition and the
question and and
then and whether we can give guarantees
and i think we're exploring
so i don't have a good answer works your
question is a really great one because
it touches on a lot of things that i
think are really
important with respect to generalization
with respect to elaboration
tolerance or even with respect to you
know us as human beings wanting to just
go in and
and and update uh you know manually
update even something that's that's been
learned and how robust is that structure
going to be
and and and can we do we have to start
learning from scratch again or can we we
learn from a point where we're going to
be able to benefit from from what we've
already learned and i think it sort of
depends on
on the gender the level of
generalization
of in the in the reward structure what
you're actually you know
what you're actually learning and um
and uh and um and how robust it is so
one nice example that we had
um the that work that i talked about the
icaps 20 work by leon elena's
one of the things that we were
interested in was using this high level
specification generating these plans
and then seeing whether these what we
had learned could be reused and
generalized
and indeed as we got more and more
complex tasks and indeed what we did
show in that paper was
where and we were using reward machine
structures with hrl
that we were learning more quickly and
so there was some
some notion of generalization but but
whether it's
it's and no guarantees of optimality you
know back to what we did before so
so um you know i think this question
that you've just asked sort of
relates to what suguman uh
also asked and and to what what you were
alluding to that which is
how much can we we pr can we can we
capture what we've we've um what we've
learned already in a form that that is
really
um sufficiently compositional that we
can reuse parts of it to learn more
quickly and so
so part of the answer is yes it depends
on on on the
the vocabulary that you're using but but
i think there's a lot more work to do in
that area that's really interesting
but i like that the the reward machine
is explainable
as you also noted and this could
possibly also lead to the option that we
just ask for an expert feedback and then
we introduce that
into learning i guess is that something
also
possible yeah so so yeah that's right
so so i mean relate related to your
basic idea but but but perhaps a little
bit different
um we had a paper at aaa 21 this year
where we were trying to learn
interpretable classifiers
and we were learning you know using we
were using automata
to learn binary classifiers for for
sequential data and and indeed one of
the things that we argued was that
because this was a formal language it
was
it was learning the pattern language of
these
these discrete um of this discrete
temporal data
um for classification purposes but that
you could actually
go in and do surgery on the classifier
and modify it if you wanted to add
another property to it
you could verify certain properties of
it and and so i think these
you know using i mean to the to the
point of this audience who who
conceivably all love automata and formal
languages
um i think you can do a lot with these
automata even beyond reinforcement
learning and reward machines but in the
media
of machine learning where where these
interpretable
um these interpretable classifiers these
interpretable rewards
these interpretable function
representations that are both generators
and acceptors of certain languages can
can be used in all sorts of different
ways that
for interpretability as long as that
vocabulary that you're using
is interpretable to a human being so
it's really exciting
and of course i want to say you know
we're not the only ones who are using
automata there's there's very nice work
that other people are doing you know of
course rajiv and his students are
have done work suguman has done work who
i
i've seen some of her work before as
well um
and and alan fern and cool and and
various other people are now looking at
um people at ut austin top queue
there's all sorts of work now going on
in this area but i think the the work we
did on reward machines was interesting
because it was
early and we also had this idea of
giving
the reward function structure to the
reward machine and of course that's
something we do in formal line
we do that in our other domains now
anyways you know obdd's or all sorts of
other things where functions are store
bayes nets where functions are
structured in a way that we can exploit
that structure so i think it's
a really great um avenue for work
thanks a lot for the pointer i'll take a
closer look yeah and then
send me email if you want in a week when
my marks are in
i mean i have a related question about
reward machines so there seems to be a
fundamental tension between
being able to write reward machines in
higher level languages for which you get
very big automata if you translate even
from ltl you can get exponentially
larger ones
and the qrm algorithm that essentially
is linear in the number of states of the
reward machine
so have you thought about this as soon
as i start using you know variables and
so on
in the language where i want to specify
these reward machines
or booleans and so on i will get very
big reward machines right and then the
learning will not converge so fast right
right so yeah so i have i guess i have a
couple of answers and maybe a couple of
ideas so
so interestingly so so the
before we did reward machines we had a
paper
at amas where we were using linear
temporal logic
straight you know without translating
because there is this potentially doubly
exponential blow up when you go from ltl
to
to uh to a dfa and
and uh we're just actually and i i was
also curious
as to whether yeah but the algorithm was
similar that we were we were decomposing
the ltl using
progression basically you know so
consuming you know
satisfy getting rid of what we'd already
satisfied and then progressing the the
ltl formula
and and the results seem to be quite
quite similar
ltl didn't i thought that ltl might be
better but but
but it didn't seem to be at least for
the problems that we
um we were working on we're doing some
work right now where we're looking at
anaphase
as well and you know of course
alternating automata which don't have
that blow up problem
we're another thing but but i can tell
you you know from from work that we've
done
um and it's work that i cited at the end
of
of my talk jorge baier um and uh
christian fritz and megan bienvenue and
various
of my students about you know 10 or 12
years ago where we were using ltl and
planning and of course came up
and ltl and automated planning and came
up with some of these same barriers that
that by by doing you know some simple
decompositions or so
on on ltl formula or doing some
engineering we could get the automotive
quite small
um the other thing another thing we did
was we used lifted representations which
helped
and then a third thing which i would say
and maybe this speaks to you
ron parr in 1997 had something called
hams which was these hierarchical
abstract machines
where he had a taunt you know basically
this these abstract machines at various
levels of the hierarchy and
and it may very well be the case that
doing something like that
these hierarchical abstract machines
might be a really great way to to deal
with the size
of these these automata and and to to
solve the problem that way so i think
that that would
an interesting thing to do but yes i'm
worried about that as well
and and i we haven't hit it yet um
in what we've been doing but but you
know the converse maybe there's
something that would make
even what we've done even faster if we
could reduce the size
so
maybe i can ask one another quick
question so
uh just from the point of view of
synthesis and i know some of the
audience does synthesis
one could have imagined that instead of
trying to learn this this automaton you
could ask
you know you could do inverse
reinforcement learning right because in
most of these domains an expert could
show you
exactly what kind of paths they want and
perhaps you could learn a reward machine
uh just from these demonstrations is
this something that you have looked
after
yeah that's right so so in a way um
in a way that's sort of what what you
know
lrm that learning reward machines was
almost like a
a uh um like a souped-up ver you know
not doing that simpler problem but doing
a harder problem in a way because we had
these traces that we were running
and we had but but we weren't just
wanting to learn the reward function
we were wanting to learn and it's
actually interesting to look at that
paper we wanted to learn a predictive
model as well
because we wanted it to be markovian so
we we needed both
both just not not characterizing just
what was reward worthy behavior
but also sufficient dynamics of the
environment
so that we could we could understand the
landscape as well
and so so i would say that that um
that work is is an example of where
we're doing it the the work on
but certainly at the we also have a
paper with alberto camacho where we
were learning and so that algorithm we
also used a variant of it in our
aaai 21 paper that i alluded to where we
were doing learning these binary
classifiers where we had noisy data and
we were basically learning these
automata and i think that's analogous to
to this this notion of doing irl and
outputting
automata but um alberto camacho also we
had some work where we were learning
um ltl from non-noisy traces
and and you can consider it a
demonstration perhaps as a non-noisy
trace and there you can learn quite
quite quickly um and we you know built
on the shoulders of other people who've
used sat solving
and other techniques for learning
automata to to sort of learn
at ltl and what we were doing we there
we were using alternating automata
skeletons
um and learning these alternating
autonomous skeletons and then piecing
them together
that represented just different ltl
pieces
and then um and then and then generating
linear temporal logic from there so
learning to linear temporal logic but
also learning
ltl so yeah but it's a great i think
there's a lot to do in this
in area and some of it we've sort of
touched upon but we haven't done it all
so hopefully
other people will will do some of this
great work
any other questions
if not well let me thank you again on
behalf of uh
everybody here and on behalf of all the
members of the simon's
semester uh thank you for giving the
talk and
um yeah so for everyone else so next
week is the
last lecture in the in the series
and next week we'll have some students
talking about
their work related to games and
equilibrium
okay thank you for coming and
have a good evening or the rest of the
day wherever you are
thanks yeah thank you sheila that was a
great talk here
thank you very much and thank you for in
inviting me and allowing me to share my
work with you is a pleasure
have a good day okay bye bye